after that damning report about the
toxic culture within the party that
internal reports saying there was a
culture of harassment bullying and
misogyny shortly after that report came
out in the middle of last week Adam
Price said he would not quit of course
there's been pressure growing for him to
go and we should say he's not had the
most successful five years or so as
leader no big breakthroughs for his
party he remained the third party here
with 12 members of the seneth of course
it matters to apply because of the
German election next year but also
potentially for Scottish for Welsh labor
they have 30 of the 60 seats here
they've got no majority and therefore
they rely on this agreement with ply to
get some more controversial legislation
through that therefore has has an impact
on on what happens to Mark Drakeford the
first minister of Wales I caught up with
him earlier do you think it's right I'm
not going to do you think to resign
that's not what I'm here for this
afternoon I mean a group of children who
are in care and are not prepared to keep
them working but you must be uh you must
be worried about what the report has
said about the culture within
explained that that's not my priority is
it time for him to go
we're joined now live by the leader of
one of the other parties in the Senate
Andrew Artie Davis the leader of the
Welsh conservatives what do you make of
Adam Price and plaid's position do you
think it's time for him to go well far
for me to comment I'm a leader of
another palatable party here leader of
the opposition but what's important is
that we do get clarity because you're
alluded in your introduction about the
cooperation agreement which is a formal
agreement with the Welsh labor party who
are in government here to deliver a
program for government and there does
need to be Clarity around that but
obviously the report that was delivered
applied last week written by one of
their former policy directors nearest
Evans her name is was quite damning and
obviously had some really uncomfortable
reading for anyone who thinks applied
deserved to be in in a better place now
we've been trying to speak to apply
politicians here in Cardiff today
they've not wanted to speak on camera
but of course you've been in the Senate
what are they privately saying about the
future of Adam Price well they've
obviously got this meeting this evening
which could pull any number of levers to
obviously put an interim leader in place
or continue to back the current leader
but what as I said from my position as
The Surge of lead and leader the
opposition is required in the interest
of Wales and the people of Wales is
Clarity and certainty because obviously
there's this cooperation agreement which
is a formal agreement with the Welsh
labor government chair and do you think
Mark Drakeford should end that agreement
well I think it's been strongly hinted
by some of his back benches Ken skates
for example is a former economy Minister
some 10 years standing in the previous
Welsh government has alluded to the fact
that they could be tarnished by some of
the allegations within the report that
was delivered applied last week and so
really they do have to decide whether
they want to stay in the same bed as
blyde given obviously that members
implied have identified this as
corporate bullying corporate misogyny
and corporate sexism as a report
identified